and then can you just speak to the  definition of pressure what you think of  when you hear that what it means to you  well my mom had to go through and my  grandma had to go through seeing myself  my brother Milo my cousin and my my  little cousins mother little cousins you  know going to work getting up at 5:00 in  the morning and getting up and going to  work and making me cereal having a bowl  of cereal sitting in the refrigerator  with some milk and being able to provide  for me and my brother and my family  that's pressure  that's pressure to me and just a willing  to do whatever it takes to make sure  that your kid will see better than which  you've ever seen and getting up and  taking public transportation an hour and  half away you know and people like that  are you know  heroes to me and just going to work and  grinding and doing whatever it takes to  provide for your family and you know  protect what you have protect